papà mi devi fare la intro del video
allora mi devi dire da tutti ragazzi
benvenuti a questo nuovi deo dire al
mondiale di real meroi al perché dico
prima di me da tutti i ragazzi a tutti i
ragazzi benvenuti a questo nuovo video
di area romana il grazie di guardare qui
questa è ok si parla così non mi va bene
importa una visione è vero
il primo richiamo un po più parsimoniose
vinceremo
se nei fatti pesca bevi madonna che
schianta in mezzo agli alberi così così
non mi colpì la mia mossa anche adesso
marito e gente da un c'è un robot né ed
nord è dietro il legna che davano nella
dietro lo prese o 400 gli hotel da
sempre li ha solo una revolver e sta
scappando si vedono vederti gran dolore
sì però non va bene slitta così giorno
c'è una revolver e leggendaria fa
percepire nulla e così ecco perché mai
arrivato così tanto la vita fa per te io
uso quella dello scudo e lascio questa
volta per imac think it so much a me dai
facciamo tanto mi faccio varmo
leggendari non mi interessa nient'altro
perché mi fa cagare lasciati ma adesso
non si può più craftare l'arma
leggendaria la porge la trave dentro non
puoi no o c'è un tipo lafarge attimo gli
ho curato un genere l'assassino ha la
forza di te
paghiamo lo facciamo lo grande eccolo
qua ancora gente quel pollo piccoli
volta non capisco se sei tu e qualcuno
che vi sta per fare in faccia io c'è un
problema comunque questo guerriero non
esco mai raggiungere dal tour e ogni
volta arrivo intanto così e poi è caduto
rovinosamente a riguardo ai tempi cova
giusta preferisco le tipiche di salice e
già fanno cagare il gioco che ti dice di
sfida se la metà sarà l'attesa metto nel
tè leggendario la roba normale rara no
noi che non legge le abilità giusti
athena temi fotografici andiamo anche
leggenda porgo le scuse ma spara da non
lo so perché escono mi piace adesione
senza c'è un robot e lo vedo non la vedo
con salve possa dare una mano cilio
cilio bravi decisa o c'è un altro e un
altro ancora l'attenzione
no non ci credo
poi con dame e come faremo azioni
nasconde un attimo però a farmi di
imprese 77 società l'ho preso gli
arrivati 800 aveva ancora un po di roba
vera dove fai pure in cima a questo
edificio se vuoi nasconderti dai porco
schifo maledetto ma solo uno tra falli
fuori io sono più pollock e umanista
partita ma fai casino quando gli altri
ti sentono che fai poco photoblog posti
poi uccisi entrambi bravi in polli detto
gli uccelli ucciso porto porco eccomi
tom è senza di me cosa faresti è la se
bisogna un po muove o dove abbiamo vinto
da trattata con questa attenzione e
questa questa andiamo a vista se questa
maniera vince questa sì si vince peccato
non si possa cambiare arma cavallo
scegli con pane ingaggiato poi come la
regione con macchie di me lo sai che ha
insegnato serio è fondamentale e
simpatica streaming e beh ora ci ha
sentito balzana idea del rumore tra
l'altro allora sentivo anch'io ho
ragazzi lenzi mitragliatrice no loro
estiva liti in casa c'era traccia non la
prendono non aprendo tra i pesi e due
contro uno due contro uno contro uno due
contro uno vai dove cazzo da renault e
non so 2 contro 1 tom tagli ai chi lo
vedo e dentro una casa che si intesta
spesa in testa è libero ma dai non ha
tolto 1200 tolta al trial 3200 di vita
qua in questo da questa parte della casa
però è andato su
ho mollato
attendo il rumore di ciao carissimo
grazie ovviamente a te l'onore è proprio
perché sei un signore anche jean mi sto
godendo grazie già è stato fra tutto il
tempo grazie è stato proprio sento la
musica che mi entra nell'anima non è
stato proprio anche per la partita
grazie io lo so che ti faccio questi
favori a farti vincere ogni tanto era da
e bisogna chiama grazie prego prego ti
guardi noi potremmo andare a s'aggirano
a lost forge al tempio eccomi sul tetto
private mi chiamo guarda bene avevo già
uno è gente mi sa che devo qualcosa fa
vicino no signora lo sentivo un pezzo
alterati in 20mila 15 c'è gente e uno a
nord ovest dietro questa stata guerra è
morto c'è ancora uno che ho colpito
grande è un pollo pollo collo ok o si
sente passato di me preso dall ingegnere
preso di nuovo l'ingegnere perfetta un
ratto gli ho tolto mille e modi morto no
è la sua velocità
ok discovery e ignori la gallery let's
go looting questa roba auto rifle era r
l'hanno inserito fucile carino e giusta
ma guasta muccio avevano queste società
perde e ho fatto un action che si è
messo a piangere giusto violento è
andata di culo che ha adorato nord 1
torto lascia d'oro e vada man 2 ciao
lassato fortissima iata male
ma ndo vai tu toglie è fortissima lascia
fidati per caricando rallentato mai lo
cediamo più grande lo regala fuori un
ottimo non ne aveva avuto lascia o di
800 sempre o no madonna e il tuo gli 800
e le banche danni a tempo ahimé perché
quella elementare di fuoco sopra
sì esatto che allora è che incentra così
evvai andare ai seni chi mi è piaciuta
come idea visto non se l'aspettavano il
maghetto boom super sneaky al iloveyou a
ma qua è aperto per forza e per quella
mentre il piazzista forge un po comica
visto eh sì ma c'è qualcosa di finissimo
che non puoi proprio questa la volta
buona per me la sento per la film sento
ma sentono sento arrivando a guardare
eccola no no questa fetta attenzione
ecco ecco ecco ecco ecco ecco la nostra
mente ecco la grande e la rete
bellissima
grazie beh adesso sì che abbiamo vinto
starete mannaggia solo quella che poi
non è che è più probabile delle altre
semplicemente che non spiegano bene uno
su quattro si abbassa non è che le dice
che per cento esce sempre grande la rete
che schifo spettaori e via tensione ci
provavano fatto anche 360 tra l'altro
non ha mai peccato nessuna immagine due
ore dopo in barca ma don madonna me ne
vado con abilità fisica del gioco part
nella scuola rete bella e
importantissima quella cominciamo il
pugnale porca vacca che male c'è la
parabola madonna ma che male ma che male
grande grande grande grande grande
occhio si stanno arrivando qua c'è chi
minaccia questo questi pollo una
maledizione
porca eva ma dài dài terzo posto no ora
va a cagare dalla ho capito tre volte
con la chiamo affatto essere vic
uccideva mosti 2 rimaneva meglio contro
un era l'ultimo fu l'ultimo
combattimento era questo sì credo mai
perché che sfiga sono stati bravi perché
ci hanno veramente acquistato subito
però porca vacca che sfiga quindi
ragazzi se il video vi è piaciuto
lasciate un commento anche su youtube ci
vediamo la prossima della ragazza potrei
dare un sacco di milioni di iscritti
comunque perché la maglia rimedi
internet in tutto questo c'è la firma mi
aspetta
ecco la bellissima fantastico
[Musica]